so today our daily cancellation deals
with one of the crucial issues
facing our country and indeed all of
western civilization and that would be
emojis
specifically male induced emojis or mie
as they are called in the medical field
last night i was actually trending i was
trending nationwide on twitter
and you can see the photographic
evidence right here trending nationwide
and also hundreds and hundreds of
infuriated private messages because of
something i said about emojis
now you might say that this is a
reflection of the fact that we live in
the dumbest most frivolous and utterly
decadent culture in world history where
even in the midst of
crisis a guy's tweet about emojis
manages to grab hold of the country's
attention
but i prefer to think that i was
trending because i'm just a really
important and brilliant guy
tomato tomato you can interpret it
however you like
whatever the reason here was the tweet
that
brought the world to a halt i said every
day i see more grown adult men using
emojis
there is no excuse for this emojis are
for children and women
do you think your great-grandfather
would have been caught dead using emojis
if the internet existed back then
have some self-respect for god's sake
bless you doubt that i lest you doubt
that i am i am kind and merciful i did
make this allowance i said gifts are
okay though
memes are a case-by-case basis okay now
so those are the rules now
before i elaborate here let's go through
some of the responses to this tweet
about emojis
as i said many many very angry people
let's take a look at a few john pavlovic
says well i hear my great
grandfather wasn't big on insecure dude
bro misogynist
so he'd laugh at matt walsh for his
transparent overcompensation and point
out that his christianity is short one
jesus
and then he called matt a fragile tiny
clown
tom thorne chimes in alexa show me what
the most pathetic toxic masculinity
looks like
gibson john's uh with a totally normal
and sane response to a tweet about
emojis which has since been deleted but
it said
masculinity is a disease
again that was a response to what i said
about emojis james fell
once again very healthy very normal he
says i've never used emojis
as a professional writer i don't like
them but instead prefer to challenge my
vocabulary that being said
this sanctimonious sack of otter snot
what a brainless festering
knuckle eat excrement and expire early
matt
okay telling me to die because of what i
said about emojis nothing overblown
about that
then alan zilberman comments with a
bunch of poop emojis
um david lauer is one of many to leave
the middle finger emoji kayla says
children and women ugh some sexism and
toxic masculinity all rolled up into one
set abramson is in on the action he
comments that this comment is beyond
is is stupid beyond belief as well as
misogynistic goes without saying to
anyone who reads my feed
but as a separate point every comment
i've ever received from a male trumpist
had an emoji in it which makes trumpist
matt walsh saying this
truly mind-blowing yes i'm a trumpist
now
sure okay uh jake wilson with the middle
finger emoji says
you managed to be homophobic and
misogynistic in one joke
so it's homophobic to make fun of emojis
now apparently emojis are an integral
part of gay culture according to jake
wilson anyway
you'll learn something new every day and
then a lot of this kind of thing in the
private messages as you can see
telling me to eat excrement calling me a
bigot
bigoted against emojis the pro emoji
guys seem to have a real thing about
eating excrement i don't know i guess we
can we can dig into the psychology
behind that some other time
and then mike williams says men are so
fragile on this site
and the crazy thing is he's apparently
talking about me
and not talking about all the grown men
hysterically crying because i made fun
of their little pictures
now i have a few things to say here okay
first i start with and i don't often do
this as you know but i
i start with uh an apology
after reading all of these responses and
and really getting a sense for how
people are
feeling uh feeling about it how it
affected them
i'd like to apologize that i said emojis
are for women and children i would i
should have mentioned
that they're also for illiterates so i
apologize for that oversight
second point um to the people who are
angry that i lumped women and children
together all i have to say is this
if you're a woman and you want to be
lumped in with children when the ship is
sinking
giving you that vip pass to the front of
the lifeboat line
then you have to put up with being
lumped together in these sorts of
insulting generalizations
that's the price of admission i think
it's a pretty good deal i i have to say
i'd take it if the ship was sinking and
someone said okay you could get off with
the children but that means we get to
make fun of you later
fine um third point the real reason
though that i will allow emojis for
children
is that we cannot expect more
sophisticated communication from them
you know if you're at if you're at the
age where you still read books with
pictures then
it's okay to type with pictures too i
allow them for women because along with
the fact that they don't have to drown
on the titanic
they also are more aesthetically
inclined they like to make things look
pretty and pleasing to the eye women are
also more exuberant and emotional emojis
are useful to this end
though only within reason i will not
allow them for men
because men don't have any of these
excuses as men
we communicate our meaning plainly and
without the frills
you shouldn't need the assistance of
smiley faces you should be able to
convey your message
by using words in the form of complete
sentences
you know i think of emojis much the same
way i think of ketchup
ketchup which is also by the way only
for women and children
if you feel like your ketchup like like
like you need ketchup for your french
fries
that only tells me that your french
fries are not well seasoned
if you feel like you need emojis for
your sentences that only tells me that
your sentences are not well seasoned
that is
you have not done a sufficient job of
expressing yourself through the use of
actual language you have not
you have not the vocabulary to season
your written expressions
with language that creatively conveys
your meaning
i think what we're witnessing in modern
times is the collapse of language
the collapse that's why people say you
know they need the emoji so that
others will know their tone and their
meaning when they text or email or post
something on social media
they don't have the ability to get their
point across in an effective way
so they need little signs little
drawings that essentially say
me happy me like that's what every
smiley face emoji says by the way
that to translate it into language it
would be me happy
or me sad or me laughing you funny
emojis are quite literally the language
of the caveman
in fact many of the responses to my
point
cited in defensive emojis cave paintings
responses like this with a photo of some
cave paintings which is supposed to
prove that emojis
are an acceptable form of communication
for modern civilized man
but this is like trying to dispel the
idea that pop music is degenerate by
arguing that they played in strip clubs
your argument against my point actually
illustrates my point precisely
yes prehistoric man before the invention
of sophisticated written language did
use a form of emoji
when they were scrawling messages on the
wall of a cave but we should no more
seek to emulate the caveman's
communication
style than his medical practices or his
hygiene routine
we have graduated beyond those crude
forms a return to them is not a good
sign in this case
with writing and language it's a sign
that people are losing their ability to
convey
meaning through the written word that is
not a positive development
and so emojis are canceled
all men who use them are cancelled
everyone who jumped on the twitter dog
pile is cancelled
or to express this in a way you'll
understand you bad
you stupid you not right good
you cancelled i hope that clarifies
things
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
uh be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content